minister
guests
it's a pleasure for me to inve to greet
you here to the first event
of our series on transformation
in the years to come
we plan to hold
regular events opening up our house to
discuss issues around transformation and
how to make a success of it
i'm very pleased to say that the weather
is on our side today allowing us
to meet at this beautiful
location as the venue for our debate
things were very quiet here for the last
two years because of the pandemic
which makes it particularly um
which makes it particularly great that
we're able to meet here today
the social and climate transformation
is the major political
challenge of our time
we have to make our economy climate
neutral and at the same time
ensure that society
stays cohesive
i think that we will manage it
but to do so a precondition will be to
ensure
that we can continue to live in freedom
and democracy in the future
during our conversations on
transformation
we plan to speak with experts from
society
politics
science and economics in order
to have a look at all different
perspectives
and it's anything but chance that
we've chosen a
fair ecological transition in europe as
our first topic the russian aggression
against ukraine and the very many
serious consequences of that war
that we see dnd out show us how
important solidarity
and cohesion are in europe not just for
our prosperity but also for our freedom
this is a very challenging task ahead of
us
and it is for that reason that our
strategy for transformation must be a
european one
who better to discuss that with us than
the president of the european commission
president jose van der lion so a very
big thank you for being here today
i'm very very pleased to have you here
as our everyone in as is everyone in the
audience i'll i'm pleased
to give the flow over to anna galenik
who is the leader of szdf studios in
brussels and will soon become the
deputy head of the
city
of the
central of zdf
we're very pleased to have you here
it means that i can now step off the
platform and hand over to you
good evening to everybody from me as
well ms wonderland please sit over here
mr habeck on the other side no i don't
want to delay we've got 15 minutes
time for our discussion
between the three of us
and then we'll have a few minutes for
questions from the audience and we're
going to have some questions that were
sent in previously as well so good
evening to everybody
and think about what questions you might
like to pose later let's begin with you
mr habeck
you're at home here
and current events certainly will play a
role in this can you talk to us about
the gas level perhaps to begin with
now i know that people sometimes think
that this is an instrument that was put
in place to anger the
german public but that's certainly not
the case it's an important instrument
when it comes to ensuring gas supply for
the german population this is an
instrument that was put in place to deal
with costs
it is unusual maybe
but without this companies would have
had no chance
they wouldn't have been able to purchase
gas
it's unusual that such extensive costs
get passed down to customers and so
there are a whole lot of difficulties
and problems tied in with this
but all of this comes off the back of
our dependence
when it comes to energy
now that dependence was developed
consciously by people in this room when
it comes to gas and energy
we need to build up our own autonomy and
we're paying the price for what we did
in the past now
this is something that we have heard
from politicians we've heard it on talk
shows it was something that was put
forward as rhetorical but that's not the
case this is something that is the
bitter truth unfortunately
we need to put in place support measures
the state needs to provide support but
we need to make sure that we move away
from the dependence that we had in the
past
we're not going to wave a white flag to
uh putin
we are going to need to move forward
with the sanctions with all the measures
that we have in place and part of that
is ensuring that we can provide gas to
our populations winter is on the way so
this is certainly something that's going
to be part of the public debate in the
future as well
now it seems
that you talk about the anger that
exists when it comes to this gas study
why is it so difficult to uh distinguish
between those companies that needs this
levy and those that don't well it's not
difficult to distinguish there are
companies who are making profits and
companies who aren't making profit
sometimes that's a bit difficult to see
when it comes to transparency and
openness of information but what the
difficulty is here
is the regulation and the legislation
that's in place applies to all it
applies
and we have now a situation where uh
only 10
of uh facilities are actually
affected by this
we can still provide gas
and do so in a way that meets the
legislation that's in place as well
on the gas
if you've not been helping
the commission has said that vat can't
be taken off of gas what is it that the
commission
would like to suggest for for
governments to help
take the burden off of companies well
firstly on vat says the commission
president a few years a few months ago
we decided on rules for vat in europe
and we can't just throw them overboard
in one fell swoop we made proposals at
that time and have come forward with
other proposals since about how we can
ensure that vat is as
simple as possible and to apply it and
the most sensible way possible for a
situation such as this
if i could
say we are in a very
serious situation which has been
triggered by putin's manipulation of the
gas market amongst other factors
we have to remember that this kicked off
last summer
when
alongside
[Music]
that was the start of all this we then
saw an increase in demand for gas in
china because it was coming out of of
the covered economic paralysis things
have changed on that front since then
but it was then that gas prices and
energy prices began to rise
the situation we have now is a very
difficult one
we've had a drought this summer because
of climate change which has led as a
knock-on impact to
less energy from hydropower 26
less energy from hydropower in the eu
it means that there are lots of
different components which are causing
the difficult situation we're in the
main one is putin's manipulation an
attempt to use gas as a weapon but there
are other factors flowing into the
situation
moreover
we shouldn't give in to the illusion
that this can be solved quickly the
energy question and exactly what energy
mix we have is one which is going to be
on our plate for a long time it's a
global trend at this moment
the commission put together a
toolkit along with the member states
about how they can support their
companies
the excess profits
tax plays a major role it can be used
then
to provide targeted support to
vulnerable households and companies as
assistants to them and that's important
because
they have to get all of the support they
need because they simply can't offset
the spirit of good position on their own
but we've now reached a stage where
we see that the electricity price
reacts in such a skittish way that
the different components which i
mentioned a moment ago
have
taken on such speculative nervousness
that we are now having conversations
around what intervention we are going to
have to take
initially with some sort of short-term
emergency intervention
we're working on that hand in hand with
the member states and secondly
and this is more
structural and long term we're going to
have to
reform the electricity market
currently gas dominate dominates the
price of the electricity market many of
you here in this room will know there
are different sources of energy and the
last one on board the most expensive one
dominates and marks the price that's
been the case for a long time but with
these exorbitantly high gas prices what
we see is we're going to have to
decouple
also what we're going to have to do a
second point is ensure that renewable
energies can be generated at very lower
costs
that that can that those costs are the
ones passed on to end users and that
and we should ensure that
the windfall profits are used to support
the vulnerable and small companies who
desperately need help
well we'll come back to the electricity
and markets and the reform
we'll be expecting some details from you
on that uh later perhaps but uh let me
stick with the gas prices and the excess
profits
tax
when you speak with your colleague the
minister for advance about that and
about a potential uh excess profits tax
will that be discussed
yes we do have a a meeting uh tomorrow
uh from about 10 to
12 and we'll see perhaps whether we can
address
that issue and how that ties in with
what's going on at the moment in europe
these
talks about transformation
i mean what we thought here was
something that would be about uh
industry transition etc and climate
neutrality however we have other
transitions on transformations ongoing
at the moment
things that are much more difficult and
that make our conditions and our context
much more difficult as well and that
needs to be taken into account as well
gas prices for example a digital
translation the social and socially fair
transition
so when we talk about uh transformation
i mean it comes from the latin word for
change
and we always
say and politics that changes something
good
in the past
people would say vote for me because you
know i'll make sure that the status quo
remains that's what we saw in the past
from politicians but today everybody
wants to change everyone's progress
but there's the flip side change isn't
always easy change comes with pain and
with difficulty
and i think that the commission
president will be able to shed light on
that very clearly
and we need to take that into account we
need to fight for
democracy in europe that's a constant
fight that we need to keep going
and the basis the foundation for that is
social equality
so
we can
you know talk about this for hours but
we need to translate our words into
action we need to take account and
recognize the crisis situation that
exists today there are so many people
who are vulnerable so many people who
are worried about trying to end meat
and we need to take those people into
account as well
there are people there are companies who
are profiting
uh more than could possibly have been
dreamed about in the past and if we
don't take action then i think we can't
make sure that the social fairness that
our democracies uh depend upon can be
maintained
so we need to uh fight for that uh
social equality above all occupation
well this debate is going on at the eu
level as well i believe there have been
three summits where the heads of state
and government have come together and
discussed the question of how we can
keep
the gas price in check there's going to
be a
council of energy ministers in next week
i believe the question has always been
that the north and south of europe are
very different perspectives the
northerners would rather not intervene
in the market they say it will sort
itself out the commission has said that
also for a very long time about prices
well the southern europeans wanted to
intervene in the market with a cap an
electricity price cap a gas price cap
what do you think may be changing now do
you think the situation is such now that
we will reach
and you shouldn't think that there have
always been two camps for all these
months and nothing's ever changed
because that's not the case
the experience of the pandemic
where each of us has looked after
themselves to begin with and try to find
national solutions which were not
successful we then realized that we had
to come together as 27 and they were far
stronger as 27 and that we could
overcome huge problems as a union
in the pandemic if i may say so we are
now the most successful region anywhere
in the world
and we're the only region in the world
who
didn't just close its borders not only
were we able to provide vaccines to our
own population we were able to send two
thirds of our production out into the
world
and we were able to overcome the very
difficult economic situation of the
pandemic which led to the next
generation eu pandemic recovery fund and
that was only possible because we're
able to find solutions together
it's not always easy it hasn't been easy
over the last year
but it's always been the goal
now we have the storage decision
together
we are successfully storing gas we have
a
shared
purchasing platform which is also quite
successful what's happened is that we
have
taken a decisive step away from putin as
a supplier of fossil fuels towards
others who are reliable
and who also share our values we have an
agreement with the united states we have
one with israel
norway has really stepped up to the
plate
and through this joint purchasing what
we've seen is that we've as putin has
reduced his gas supplies to put us under
pressure we've been able to offset it by
increasing supplies from others we've
got the winter plan in place that's the
third component and it's very important
when gas is sparse it's going to remain
scarce we have to decisively save gas
and energy
through the storage for example that's
something which has
been welcomed by the member states
well excuse me to intervene but i
believe there's always there has also
been
debates and disagreement yes says the
president but that's part of democracy
as president of the commission i can't
just present proposals and expect all 27
countries to to nod
yes but has this led to a reduction in
the price of gas the president
yes but all of these parts all these
components play a role in getting us
through the winter despite the fact that
putin is highly likely to reduce the gas
supply we're going we're basing
ourselves in the worst case scenario and
we've made improvement across the board
in all of these areas and there's one
more component which is essential i want
to mention and that is investment in
renewable energy here again we've made a
major step forward with repair eu it's
still got to be finalized
and passed through council and
parliaments but there's going to be 300
billion
invested in renewable because every
kilowatt hour of renewable energy we
generate ourselves makes us a little bit
more independent from fossil fuels
taking all of this together these are
major preconditions and if we didn't
have them in place we'd be in a far
worse position than we are now
now to your question
as a next step
we have to take
intervention we have to redesign the
market and we have to develop an
instrument which we're working on over
the next few days and weeks
whereby
we set a path so that gas prices don't
determine energy prices we have to
ensure that the lowest price energies
can make a certain amount of profit
not
indulge in such excessive windfall
profits which are well beyond their
expectations or
best case scenario imaginations and this
will help us improve our energy
situation
the thinking behind this in energy
there's always three things you need it
has to be
affordable it has to guarantee supply
i.e there has to be enough energy on the
market and it has to be sustainable
and that's why it is important to us to
ensure
that
the
price pressure that these high costs
have triggered can be used to drive
their transformation towards renewable
energy forward that's the only way out
of
the
situation we find ourselves in under
pressure about fossil fuels right now
at the same time not everyone will be
able to achieve the transformation on
their own for various reasons and we
have to support them
in
getting through this transformation by
providing the right resources
critics say that we're turning away from
uh marcus
economies here and is that fair well it
is logical
if you think about it i think some of
the criticisms that they say that we're
trying to get rid of gas companies isn't
uh fair it's not correct to say that
what we're doing
here are things that would usually take
years perhaps we're under a lot of time
pressure and we've to act in a matter of
months
so we need to keep the time pressure in
mind
as the commission president said we
should use this transition and these
measures to get rid of these windfall uh
profits that some companies are making
and we should make use of this windfall
to support those who are in need of it
and we can do that so long as we need to
until we have uh
this
problem this challenge
solved the gas uh the electricity market
works in effect it's called the marriage
order not the worst order
because the most affordable the cheapest
options come onto the market first
we've had phases in the market where
electricity has been incredibly cheap
practically free
because of course the most cheap
options are the renewable energies and
they're often entered into the market
first the highest most expensive form of
energy then sets the price for all
others so sometimes this has worked
that's
something that we have to say
and usually this leads to investment and
more money for the renewable energy so
in principle it is a system that works
and it makes sure that
we work in an energy efficient manner
however there's no elasticity in the
market if we use up all our
capacities
if there's no leeway if the
most expensive energy needs to be bought
then we end up in a situation where we
are today
and that's why we're in the problem that
we're faced with today we need to come
up with a quick solution to that problem
but we need to keep the market signals
in place otherwise it's going to be very
difficult to guarantee security of
supply
because compensation
for these uh
gas prices needs to be insured via the
market who else is going to come from
the state for example
so it needs to be we need to be careful
here and so far how far we intervene in
the market
it doesn't mean that the prices of the
merit order would apply across the board
i think we can develop a mechanism
that would promote the affordability of
certain energies amongst the suppliers
as i said we're working under
high pressure in terms of time
but we're going to work closely with
our european partners with the
commission compare and contrast our
plans and the measures that we want to
put in place
you know we've got an incredible hive
mind here with all of these various
countries
and politicians coming together so
we should take the time you know to put
that high mind to use
and to come up with a sensible logical
solution
so we need to put in place the
foundations
in order to make sure that the market
can function because i don't think a bad
design is the problem here
this is a complicated
matter
but it is possible
there are no
and this isn't a discussion for days and
weeks but for months
if you're asking me about up to
implementation
i think if all goes well weeks and
months
the president we need an emergency
instrument which would
be triggered very quickly
in weeks perhaps what i just sketched
out
is a first step and after that there's
going to have to be a deep and
structural reform of
the energy market
and i think that will come at the
beginning of next year
but
the first step
which we have today because of the
uber nervous situation on the market and
the enormous speculation because these
aren't real prices let's be clear these
are speculative jumps on the market
we have to send a very clear signal
that this far and no further
i think that it's very good that germany
has sent a signal
that
purchases
a line will be set including for storage
companies should know that they can earn
good money that this is a very
attractive market but it also has its
boundaries
and the deep
reform which has a lot of
particularities and a lot of
cogs and wheels to take into account it
has to be done properly
seriously maturely and that will come to
the beginning of next year i think
another important point
and this is what's so exciting about the
transformation is that
you have what's going on right now but
you also have the long-term track moving
along what we can see before our very
eyes right now
is
the enormous supply of fossil fuels
which has been flowing in from russia
for
decades just let me give you one figure
european
75 of russia's exports of fossil fuels
we are a huge customer
the supply that was coming in from
russia
is now going to come to an end and that
is going to be a huge change
europe currently
is on the lookout for new sources of
energy i mentioned americans the
norwegians but also algeria
egypt israel azerbaijan to name but a
few all of these things are shifting and
now is a time
when we can targetedly and massively
invest in the global south for renewable
energies we want renewable renewable
energy because of climate change but we
must be very careful because this
extreme situation
we have to be careful
that we don't get fall into a trap of
just trying to replace the fossil fuels
which we're now not getting from russia
we have to not take our eye off the ball
of renewable energies and there's a
chance in the global south where there
is a wind there is more sun than you
could ever use
we have to invest in
infrastructure for green hydrogen
and our demand and a huge supply from
the global south
tie up
so in addition to the very urgent
matters that we have to deal with now in
order to get over this
energy price crisis we have to also push
forward the long-term changes to ensure
that we don't always fall into a trap of
dependence
you talked about climate change and this
is all to uh fight climate change too as
well
yes absolutely says the minister to
applause from the audience
you talked there about uh prices and the
nervousness in the market
politicians are nervous too users are
nervous too customers are nervous too
what does all of this mean for the
european green deal
which of course encompasses a much
broader transition and which is
constantly develop running in the
background that aims to achieve time and
neutrality in europe by 2050. the
situation today does it does it help the
uh green deal or does it uh
pose a hindrance to the green deal well
of course this ties in with the green
deal and especially
in light of the um pandemic in light of
the
russian war in ukraine people constantly
said you know we can't focus on the
green deal because there are bigger
priorities uh we've bigger fish to fry
at the moment but we can't say that
i mean think of where the pandemic
came from human intervention and
disruption
in
in the environment in animals habitats
which led to more viruses being
transmitted by animals so it all comes
back to our
uh
action
and
how we treat the environment
and of course the energy crisis that
we're experiencing today is tied with
the uh climate change and the problem
we're facing there as well
it's all down to fossil fuels for
example
which have led to uh greenhouse gas
emissions
and we need to put everything into the
european green deal here now and
promoting it and driving it forward
this is the road map we have
that will take us through to 2013 and
our emissions reductions targets for
them and then 2050 and becoming climate
neutral by then
so this is a better more healthy more
environmentally friendly future for us
for our society for the environment for
our economy it will lead us towards a
circular economy
where we
can actually give back to the planet
instead of taking from it as we've been
doing as we've been exploiting it
up until now
we need to take care of our raw
materials and our raw material supply
that ties in with the european green
deal as well
we need to focus on
food production and supply i spoke about
biodiversity and environment already
i've talked about energy
the situation we are faced with today
are ones that we'll be dealing with in
the long term and that certainly tie in
with climate change i mean we have
created climate change humans have
created climate change there's no
question about that think of the
droughts we've seen this summer think of
the floods the extreme weather
phenomenon that we've seen once again
and this is just the beginning of the
impact of climate change so it's high
time that we take action here
the green deal will be painful for some
for example by putting a price on co2
we will need politicians that are able
to explain not just energy and gas
prices are going up but also co2 prices
for buildings and transport
do you think that
in europe and i don't mean just german i
also mean eastern europe for example
there's an off-sited bulgarian granny
for example
do you think this is really
something that we can push through that
can be explained to people
well i think that we have to explain
what the alternative is
nothing is without alternative i think
in politics always has been alternative
but here the alternative is worse
the alternative would be to throw your
hands up and say that it's complicated
and there'll be difficult discussions
and that the process might be difficult
and that we can't foresee
exactly what the outcome of the
transformation process will be and
therefore we shouldn't go ahead with it
always described the capitalist economy
as a process of destructive creation
something will always be created but
there are consequences
something has always got to be given up
structural change is the word that we
often use for the loss of old industries
and jobs but it's parts an integral part
of transformation without it there could
be no transformation
it would just be the same thing in a
different packaging
150 years
ago 88 90
of the population were
worked in agriculture
if you told them that only two or three
percent of people would be
farmers 150 years later they wouldn't
have understood they'd have asked you
well what are all was everyone else
doing they couldn't have understood that
all these people would be
teachers that all kids would go to
school that there would be travel
agencies the kids wouldn't have to be
digging up potatoes that they'd be
learning math and english and biology
to explain that to them would have
sounded like a foreign language they
would have asked you what kids needed
with biology
we're in a very similar position now
people aren't farmers anymore they all
work in the professions that i've
mentioned
that's a transformation that our society
has gone through with many debates
but we have become more prosperous
because of it our economy has grown
because of it our health
our income even with the levels of
poverty we have in germany our incomes
have improved that is creative
destruction
that doesn't mean
that people don't
don't mourn loss when it comes if they
have to give up their family farm
because nobody wants to take it over
and if things move very fast if there's
huge political pressure because of the
emergencies of the day if things have to
move very fast then the transformations
which in the past perhaps took
decades 100 years if that's the
transformation we have to push 320 years
then it represents a huge political
challenge
in
2045
germany will be climate neutral
we're now in 2022 so we have
22 and a quarter years from a political
perspective that's tomorrow it's no time
at all and we have to turn the world's
fourth biggest
industrial country in europe and the
entire continent we have to transform it
entirely
for the birds frankly to think that that
won't cause
nasty emails and protests and debates
but that doesn't mean we should give up
the question and indeed the political
duty is for us to ask ourselves what
would happen if we don't do it
to believe that things would stay as
they were in the past
germany could stay at the germany walls
in 1980 or
2010 is an illusion the world around us
is becoming is moving ever faster
becoming ever more ambitious
transformation is happening and not just
because of reasons of climate uh climate
change which as a green is very
important to me and i'm making my
contribution the world is changing also
because of the competitiveness question
we have to keep our country competitive
we want to have a prosperous future
steel production is going to change
chemical production is going to change
in the future the world around us is
going to change as well the products
that we need are going to change
the
the crux of the matter is
this will be painful it will be
difficult but
at the end of the day as a society we
will
prosper from this change and what we as
politicians have to do is ensure that
those who are
who lose out on a temporary basis who
have to take the pain are supported in
order to make our way into the future as
a country and a continent
we cannot however
give in to the temptation of believing
that
the solution that was the right answer
in 1980 will continue to be the right
answer in 2020 because that's an
illusion
so what we need to do is quite clear and
there's been a lot of talk about it but
how do we actually do that how do we
ensure that poland for example uh phases
out cool
and how do we ensure that that
proverbial bulgarian granny can still
heat her home
well i want to pick up
where uh
minister habeck
left off or what he was talking about
we are europeans
our economy is a strong social economy
and i think that's a wonderful model
not just something to aspire to but it's
successful too
our success
is one that we earn one that we earn
together we all contribute to us
and we should all benefit from it
we all contribute to it so those who are
vulnerable who are suffering from
poverty or from other issues are
protected
that's what our
social economy is based on and that's
what needs to be kept at the forefront
of this transformation so it doesn't
matter whether we're talking about coal
regions here or other more vulnerable
groups ensuring that
people
perhaps experiencing energy poverty or
trying to upgrade renovate their homes
we need to make sure those
who
can afford to do so individuals
companies countries can do so
but we also need to make sure that those
who can't afford to do so who can't
afford to do so financially for example
who have low incomes for example can
still be brought on board and can still
take part in this transformation
so at the eu level we have the just
transition fund in order to ensure that
to ensure a just transition and this
specifically targets some of the coal
regions in poland for example because
they have to
undergo massive transformation
completely change
uh in terms of what their heritage their
training their education is
and europe is fully prepared to provide
support
financial support this money is coming
from the eu budget
the money for the just transition fund
the second issue then is co2 pricing
on the polluter pays principle so if you
emit
carbon dioxide then you need to pay for
it
we've seen enormous growth since 1960 or
so for example
since 1990 we've seen co2 emissions so
it is possible to have economic growth
and to reduce our greenhouse gas
emissions and the polluter pays
principle
principal
is going to come into this this also
provides an incentive for companies
to invest more in renewable options and
to produce in a more carbon neutral way
we take a look at buildings on road
transport then
we need to make sure that we have the
social aspect covered in the sector
we need to take a look at the revenue
that we get from the co2 prices
and we can distribute that amongst uh
individuals or companies who need
this money in order to undergo the just
transition the climate transition
so we're going to have a lot of revenue
from the co2 prices on the one hand we
can invest in innovation and new
technologies that can accelerate the
transition
and this is something that we have put
forward on the commission side the
council and the parliament are still
looking at these proposals
when it comes to the social climate fund
because this will underpin our market
economy in the future
well you need to get companies on board
of course because there will be no
progress without them and they are to be
defended by a c bomb a carbon border
adjustment mechanism
that's what it's called an eu jargon
i quite like it because it sounds like
you're saying to china china bam take
that this is another commission proposal
by the way
and it's meant to ensure that products
which are produced in a
in a way which is
disruptive to
competition if if it's produced in china
pakistan india anywhere else where
climate uh goals are not taking into
account
then they will be
penalized to protect our
internal
industry but industry doesn't want c-ram
it wants to maintain the certificates it
has
the c-band mechanism is
is moving forward and it's going to come
this is not going to be an overnight
process it will come little by lit it's
all very complex to set up
it will start in
three or four
sectors where co2 is emitted in high
amounts for example aluminium
the basic principle behind the idea is
that if our industry is willing and it
has to be willing
to
become innovative
because of our high co2 prices leading
to situations where no longer produces
aluminium with gas for example with
green hydrogen
well then our industry will have taken a
huge step forward it will have developed
co2
free aluminium but that development
innovation costs money if at the same
time
dirty aluminium is coming into europe at
a cheaper price from china
then it's almost impossible for our
companies to sustain and justify
innovation
but we need innovation to in order to
stop
polluting the environment
and that's why we've told china if you
come to our market with dirty products
then you're going to have to pay
customs levy for the co2
that is caused by your products but
we've also said we don't really want the
money we'd rather that china set up a
co2 certificate
system a level playing field is what we
call it to ensure that there's fair
competition
china not because of cbam but
nonetheless china is in the process of
bringing in a co2 price system
and china's recently come to the
commission and asked us about the
experience that we have the mistakes
that we've made in the past so that they
don't fall into the same mistakes and
that's exactly what it should be we
should be creating incentives to ensure
that when products come to our market if
they are dirty products then they pay a
price because our companies here in
europe are investing huge money in
developing cleaner products
and by setting up a system like this you
encourage
other competitors to also be innovative
and to bring
clean products to the market to create
clean competition
what about the companies what did they
think about siba are they in favor well
yes they are i mean it's a very logical
idea
during the fit for 55
negotiations
we talked about this before the
parliamentary recess i think this is one
of the biggest successes
uh in terms of what europe has done this
year
i think there are about 18 different
files in total covering everything from
agriculture to sebum
to
the
directive on e-fuels
as well
to the renewable energy directive the
second one so they were incredibly
complicated negotiations and there
certainly was a whole section on cbam
as well on our side
and the solution that we found which we
was found was a satisfactory one was
that we wouldn't start off with a linear
system
so we'd have a higher proportion of uh
allowances at the beginning
so that companies can get involved in
the
transition right at the outset
and then each year will have a change
now this is quite a complicated
negotiation process
and the council always try to be more
conservative that parliament more
ambitious perhaps
and then we try to find a compromise we
all get together and try to find an
agreement that's uh you know what makes
europe so interesting and the fact that
we managed to do that is a huge success
especially the fact that we managed to
get the agreement on a cbam as well
and since then i don't think i've heard
any complaints as i said beforehand
there was a very in-depth debate
we already hashed it all out but i think
we have found a way forward now
well you've said what politics has to do
what companies have to do
but what does europe have to do how does
the eu have to change
in order
to make a success of this transformation
makes lots of proposals and suggestions
about what others have to do
remember my question
is as it were how do the institutions
have to change themselves
in order for europe to be successful in
this transformation
well it's very important that we agree
to these rules together at the european
level the the european green deal is
unimaginable
achieving a circular co2 free economy
would be impossible otherwise
there is
the world is competitive it'd be very
difficult to make any progress if all of
the countries were competing against one
another the commission has the right of
initiative it's come forward with a
roadmap from the very beginning the very
first
climate law
ever in europe was brought forward by
the commission and under it all 27
member states have signed up to achieve
our
major goals and that creates a legally
binding framework so it's not a question
of whether we will become climate
neutral by 2050 but how we get to
climate neutrality
and the and that leads us to the four
big legislative packages
because every part of
life and economy in the european union
is going to
and council are scrutinizing the
proposals very closely negotiations are
ongoing
and time is ticking we have to pick up
the pace
europe isn't necessarily known for
picking up the pace uh for acting
quickly well when we're under pressure
we can get the job done think about the
pandemic think about the digital covert
certificates and what we managed to do
it took us three months to do that
from the first thought to actually
getting it up and running
and this was the only digital covert
certificate on a worldwide basis that
actually made it to the market and then
everybody copied our lead
so
you can see that you know
sanctions again the second day the
fourth day the sixth day after the
beginning of the war we had sanctions
packages on the table and a couple of
days later we had those approved
so where there's a will there's a way
i'm not here to defend the european
system of course we do need to
constantly uh work on this improve
and step up
our speed
but i just do want to point out that
this is a complicated issue
it's part of our democracy there are 450
million
europeans there are 27 member states
we're not going to be act as quickly as
an autograph like putin who can uh you
know
stamp a certain document and it will be
implemented the next day
our sister might be so but it's a
democratic one
well
chancellor schultz gave a speech today
in prague and i wanted to pick up on it
he said
that we are going to have to move away
from the veto if we are to make progress
and to pick up the pace in decision
making in the future
i wonder if that
if this transformation is the crisis
we're facing now provides an opportunity
to make changes
and move towards majority decision
making in many areas such as
environments
well
many of the packages on the environment
which are on the table fall in
full under majority
voting
calculation tables
determine
the qualified majority voting it all
depends on how many citizens there are
in each member state and adding them up
so it's not just a question of the 27
member states having 14 states on in
favor and 13 again
it also depends how many how many
citizens each member state has it
requires very intelligent people to
check some very complicated calculation
tables
chancellor schultz today mentioned
foreign defense and security policy and
i agree with him it's
awful
political events happen in the world
things move very fast and one member
state in the eu can
force the eu in its entirety into
silence by voting against a declaration
and then people turn doesn't say well
why are you saying why are you not doing
or saying anything and we can't because
of unanimity if
even one vote is filibustering
and that is why i agree that we have to
move towards qualified majority voting
the problem is the obstacle is that you
need
unanimity
to change the rules you need a one-off
unanimity to get the rules changed and
that's what will probably be the
obstacle
moderator so that will never be achieved
yes it says mr havoc under pressure
so we let the audience know that they
could ask questions as well at the
beginning
and i haven't turned to the audience yet
so i do have a question from martin hawk
from linkedin what does climate
fairness mean to you
it's the title that we
went for for this
so talk talking today about how we can
achieve uh you know a socially fair
transition in europe that's what the
title of the talk is go ahead
well i'm talking about i'm can think of
climate change on the one hand and
social fairness on the other hand and
bringing those two components together
i think that's what's encompassed by
this uh
this heading this title
but this is just off the cuff what i'm
thinking
we will not be able to achieve a
transition if it is not a socially fair
one it has to be a social green
transition or no transition at all so
both of these aspects the fairness and
the climate are very closely tied
together yes for sure that's one aspect
says uh minister habek
on the other hand we need to make sure
that those countries who have done
something don't
you know
fail to shoulder their responsibilities
richer economies richer countries like
germany for example
need to
be pioneers here we can't wait for
everybody to get on board we need to
lead the way and then support others as
well
we need a socially fair distribution of
the responsibilities of climate change
as well
so it also deals with how
uh
climate policy and responsibility is
distributed across the world as well
yes just a couple of things that are
important as well let's take a look at
ourselves in the european union because
we only make up a small amount a small
percentage of emissions but if we can
show the world that we can be successful
that we can't create a circular economy
that we can become a climate neutral
economy through innovation that we can't
become a successful prosperous economy
by doing this then we can
set a huge excellent example for the
world and i think that's really
important for our companies as well
that the innovation that we have in
europe is recognized on the world stage
because what we're creating here are the
future uh markets and
economies secondly then
a view to countries that aren't as
industrialized we have a particular
responsibility when it comes to these
countries because we expect a lot from
these countries we expect them not to
make the same mistakes that we made we
expect them not to fall into the fossil
fuel trap
we expect them to take a leap of faith
toward renewable energies immediately
and we can only do that if we can
provide financial support in order to
allow them to do this
so this is all set in the paris
agreement
europe is doing its part others aren't
so we have difficulties there
and
some of the emerging economies around
the world are rightfully angry about the
lack of support
we cannot expect
these countries to move
directly toward renewable energies and
completely forego fossil fuels if we
don't support them financially to do so
that's the fragment from felix schmidt
one final question privilege schmidt
over instagram what measures are planned
to speed up the permits process for
renewable energy
installations
well the minister we have a huge range
of measures prepared
we've
changed the methodologies used for a
whole range of environmental formats to
make them more of a one-stop-shop
process
[Music]
to ensure that there are areas where
nature can be left in peace
this has been negotiated between the
ministry for the environment and my
ministry and has never been agreed
when it comes to solar permits
we've been
we have a number of smaller technical
issues to deal with
we've made proposals
should lead to
the permit process being sped up and
simplified
of course this won't be the end of the
story we also have a working group which
is delving into all of the details
it doesn't make financial sense
because of very specific technical or
permit related reasons
and these are things that we're trying
to look at
in europe and particularly in germany
we have a problem with the permits
process and we have to speed it up and
make it simplifier simplified
the legislative branch is going to do
what it can
but sometimes it's just a little too
easy to say that bureaucracy is standing
in the way of progress
albatross i believe it was
which stood in the way
and it was used as a
as an excuse not to set up wind turbines
now several decades later we've got
hundreds of wind turbines and hundreds
of these birds
the wind turbines turned out not to be a
problem
sometimes
don't always want a solution so we all
have to play our part to move forward
other birds as well and other people
might have other questions let's turn to
the audience who has a question has
anybody got a microphone that we can use
for future
represent hundreds of thousands of
people and millions of people who have
taken to the streets who have protested
for the
climate we saw
the
uh targets and the objectives that
politicians and governments have set for
themselves in the last three years
however if we take a look at what's
actually happened
since then
it's not a lot
we're being made many promises
but these promises aren't being capped
we are here the talk of uh
infrastructure of pipelines of uh gas
being supplied from senegal where we
happen to receive gas from before
my question to you is how
do we make sure that we actually move
forward
yes we need to end our dependence from
putin that's all well and good
but how do we ensure that there's no
knock-on effect that there's no
long-term contract that we don't
accidentally create future crises in
terms of gas and other fossil fuels
because at the end of the day we're
trying to move away from these
minister havoc well your question is a
fully justified one i think we need to
make sure when it comes to potential
long-term
contracts are avoided
we need to be able to act today to deal
with the climate crisis we're facing at
the moment
if gas companies sign contracts that
take 25 years because of recourse we all
know that the more long term the
contract the cheaper it's going to be in
the long term for the company but we do
need to keep in mind that we want to
become climate news by 25 and those two
things don't tally
so
what we're doing at the moment is trying
to become more flexible trying to see
what the alternatives to russia are
we're building up infrastructure
to
become more self-sufficient in the
future to decrease our dependency
and we need to invest smartly because we
can't invest in short-term things today
that won't be of any use to us in a
couple of years at the moment contracts
that are being agreed upon are about 10
years in duration
so they're to deal with a short to
midterm crisis
but we need to make sure that ultimately
what we're trying to do today uh
corresponds with our long-term climate
goals
at the moment in germany we use around
thousand terawatts hours of uh gas
12 to 15 is electricity
and then the rest goes for industry and
for heating
we're trying to switch up our sources
our use we're trying to use more heat
pumps
we're trying to move away from gas and
towards hydrogen in in the industrial
sector at the same time we're phasing
out coal and hopefully we'll be able to
do that quicker than we initially
anticipated
because the
increase in fossil fuel and greenhouse
gas emissions we've seen recently as a
result of the energy shortage will need
to be balanced in the long term and
we'll need to offset that
so we're going to replace uh coal plants
by more renewable energies
solar wind but of course there will be
times when the wind is blowing when the
sun isn't shining and we need to make
sure that we can
deal with that and allow for that as
well
so whether that's the uh natural gas to
begin with
and then hydrogen in the long term
so at the moment we're trying to move
away from gas but we do need
transitional
solutions
we're constantly looking at the
prognosis we're constantly looking at
future trends
we think that
germany's peak gas usage will be in the
next decade in the 30s
now last year i would have told you that
it would be around 2035
but we've taken a look at that
something that needed support but that
wouldn't work
things have changed now because gas
prices are so high we have other
alternatives on the table
things that
so green hydrogen today would be a lot
cheaper than uh gas prices are
so you think that uh gas prices will
decrease in the future but they won't go
down to the level
they were when it came to the
cheap russian gas
so at the moment we're saying that we
think in the early 30s we'll reach peak
gas usage in germany
we need to
offset that usage
we need to put in place alternatives to
north stream one and two in the
pipelines and we need to decrease our
use of gas
that's why we're building infrastructure
at the moment to be able to do this
and as soon as we're ready to do so we
can make that switch to this more
renewable energy
i mean at the end of the day we need
renewable energies
we need them here at home we need them
abroad as well
but we are making sure that we don't
have a lock-in effect
this means we constantly need to keep an
eye on developments on industry on
market prices we constantly adjust our
calculations
and uh adapt our actions accordingly
and as the commission president said
when it came to the green deal we're
hearing so much about uh you know fossil
fuels about coal about lng
despite all the talk we hear about these
fossil fuels
there's a lot going on on the flip side
when it comes to renewable energies when
it comes to hydrogen things we couldn't
have anticipated
in our wildest dreams you know nine
months or a year ago so let's look at
the legislative period in its entirety
we need to get through this winter
and then we're going to be faced with a
different context a different energy
landscape
one that will be hopefully be much more
diverse
on the european level um
yes but people please we want one more
question
i think that it's become clear that
we're both saying tonight that we have
to work hand in hand at the same time in
the european union
and this is the point that you mentioned
a more to go minister on renewables in
the eu
we've
set a goal of reaching
we had a goal of reaching 49ers 45
renewable energies by 2030 and we're
flanking that
with investments of up to 300 billion
which will go into renewables via the
member states
what you said a moment ago on solar
we have to have a solar strategy whereby
from 2026
all newly built public buildings
are to have solar panels
in 2029 it will come in for private
buildings and we have to make decisive
steps forwards on hydrogen
we've just launched a project which is
called a project of european interest
bringing together various member states
and the european level
particularly because of the question of
the state aid which is always very
thorny
in order
to ensure that when we progress on
hydrogen puts together many scientists
academics and member state agencies
i think this shows that in all of the
different
sectors of renewables we're making
decisive progress not just on the
legislative issues but also in practice
tomorrow i'm going to denmark where
there'll be a major wind summit on the
baltic sea we had one a few weeks ago
for the north sea
the north sea is setting up an offshore
wind
park which will be able
to power 50 million households in the eu
with renewable power
million households is about one-sixth of
the eu
so it's very huge
if the moderator would give me a moment
with another question
but
you're flying up to denmark tomorrow i
imagine to um you're flying and it's in
ball home which is wonderful
that's the location of the first truly
european wind park project
we've always had wind parks of course
but they are national and seek to sell
the electricity now after very
complicated negotiations we've set up a
joint project
it's almost as if
you mind
countries were developing atomic energy
together back in the day
and that never ever happened so here we
have joint investments a german company
danish companies investing together and
win part together
and then sharing
the
the energy two gigabytes
for two gigawatts for germany 1.2 for
denmark
and the plans for the north sea are
another excellent cool example of how
europe is growing towards
is growing together it's integrating
one last question the young
we heard today about the green deal
and how we're looking at in light of the
war
we're hearing that there are discussions
on diluting some elements of the 5455
package at the moment
is that true we have goals in place for
decarbonization of course for climate
neutrality but then are we trying to cut
corners elsewhere
well repair eu has 300 billion
available initially
and 20 billion from the stability
and so that had an excessive pressure on
the situation that we're going through
which is a difficult one
already
so if you take 20 billion in comparison
to 300 billion it is a significant
component but what's most important is
the 300 billion that will be fed into
this by next generation eu
i think that
is time
and we're going to have to say goodbye
we heard
about
countries coming together
we can't talk about the climate
coalition we can't talk about
the coalition that doesn't
we don't have in germany at the moment
uh i would like to thank you very much
for
being here with us for listening to us
and also thank you very much to the
ministry for climate action economic and
economic affairs and thank you very much
as well to commission president trump's
live underline i wish you all a pleasant
evening
forget
[Music]
so when the cameras are off we can um
continue our discussions if we like
network a little together and i would
also like to wish you a very pleasant
evening